[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend jeder wohnt und heizt und die
meisten fahren Auto mehr als Dreiviertel
aller Haushalte hierzulande besitzen
zumindest eines damit ist auch klar dass
jede klimaschutzmaßnahme die in den
Bereichen wohnen oder Verkehr ansetzt
sehr viele Menschen sprich Wähler
betrifft das erklärt einen Teil der
politischen Erregung die wir derzeit
erleben und es erklärt auch warum der
Gebäude und der Verkehrssektor bei den
Klimazielen gewaltig hinterherhinken
dass sich da etwas ändern muss ist unter
den Bundesländern zwar unbestritten aber
bei der Debatte heute im Bundesrat über
das geplante heizungsgesetz war deutlich
zu spüren wie groß die Sorge ist die
eigene Wählerschaft zu überfordern dass
die zum Teil weiter auf fossile
Brennstoffe setzt zeigt Diana Zimmermann
zu Beginn ihres Berichts
der nächste Winter kommt bestimmt bis
dahin hat Heizungsbauer hartrad noch
einen riesigen auftragsstau abzuarbeiten
das heizungsgesetz Willen das ab Januar
2024 alle neu eingebauten Heizungen zu
65% mit erneuerbarer Energie zu
betreiben sind das sollte Öl und
Gasheizungen zur Auslaufmodellen machen
stattdessen sind sie wieder der letzte
Schrei wir bauen aktuell wieder
Ölheizungen in diesem Jahr Aufträge für
Ölheizung zum Ausbauen das ist in der
Masse so viel würde die letzten 15
Jahren nicht ausgetauscht haben seine
Kunden so der Installateur befinden sich
in Blanca Panik vor den für sie schwer
zu kalkulierenden Kosten der Wärmepumpe
das berichteten auch die
Ministerpräsidenten im Bundesrat in
Anwesenheit des Wirtschafts-
Inkrafttretens Anfang 2024 sei zu früh
die Altersgrenze von 80 Jahren für
Ausnahmen sei zu hoch die Höhe der
Förderung sei weder präzise noch
großzügig genug und es Fehler an
technologieoffenheit Wärmepumpe geht
nicht über alles auch nicht überall
machbar und deswegen ist es uns wichtig
dass wir technologieoffenheit zum
Beispiel Richtung Holz Richtung Biomasse
haben auch müsse das kommunale
Fernwärmenetz dringend ausgebaut werden
der bayerische Ministerpräsident fordert
das ganze Gesetz zu überdenken mir ist
nicht ganz verständlich warum man in der
schwersten Energiekrise unseres Landes
die noch nicht überstanden ist dann noch
einmal an das Schraube zieht und dreht
und den Gürtel noch ein Stück enger
schneiden
statt verheizen so greift die CDU seit
gestern in einer Kampagne die
Existenzängste vieler Bürger auf
massiver Gegenwind auch aus der
Koalition gleich 100 und eine bohrende
Frage sendete die FDP an den Wirtschaft
sminister
das Gesetz ist handwerklich schlecht
gemacht es ist auch technisch in weiten
Teilen nicht umsetzbar und es ist vor
allem auch ja finanziell für die
allermeisten Menschen nicht umsetzbar
und da muss man sich ja schon fragen was
soll das Ganze ja sollen wir als FDP
dafür in mit Haftung genommen werden ich
nicht bereit zu Robert Habeck hatte im
Bundesrat das Schlusswort und blieb
dabei fossiler Heizungen lohnten sich
künftig nicht schon ohne die geplante
Förderung rechnen sich eine Wärmepumpe
nach 18 Jahren und kleiner finanztipp
vom Minister Leasingfirmen die sagen wir
bauen hier das Ding ein wir beantragen
die Förderung für dich und dann zahlst
du jährlich einen Abschlag darauf und
nach zehn Jahren kannst du dich
entscheiden ob du das System haben
willst oder nicht haben willst dann
reden wir von hunderten von Euro im Jahr
und ich glaube dass dieses Modell
zunehmend attraktiv ist hier allerdings
könnte es dem Wirtschaftsminister
ergehen wie Gerhard lange folgten seine
Kunden dem Rat des Experten jetzt nicht
mehr
aber nein es ist der Markt dermaßen
aufgewühlt es wird was kommen es muss
was kommen sprachs und suchte weiter
nach der nächsten lieferbaren Ölheizung
blicken wir auf das Wochenende dann wird
eines der wichtigsten politischen
Ereignisse die Wahl in der Türkei sein
Präsidentschaftswahl und Parlamentswahl
beides gleichzeitig wenn
Oppositionsführer Kemal Kilic daolo warm
machen will was er verspricht einen
politischen Frühling für die Türkei dann
muss nicht nur er gegen Erdogan gewinnen
sondern sein Parteienbündnis auch im
Parlament eine Mehrheit erinnern die
Chance dazu ist wohl da es würde
bedeuten dass ein Autokrat abgewählt
würde dass das möglich ist
berichtet über den Wahlkampfabschluss in
der Türkei
erdogan ist nicht mehr mein Präsident
sagt Mustafa Jena olu vor fünf Jahren
kämpfte er noch für Recep taip Erdogan
heute kämpfte gegen ihn jeder Holo
wechselte zu einer der sechs kleinen
Oppositionsparteien die gemeinsam den
Präsidenten aus dem Amt jagen wollen
wofür ich stehe da hat sich nichts
geändert ich stehe nach wie vor für
Demokratie für freiheitlichkeit für
Gerechtigkeit ich stehe nach wie vor
dafür dass es in diesem Land wieder
bergauf geht dafür steht er nur nicht
mehr dafür steht jetzt die Opposition
und deswegen bin ich auf der richtigen
Seite
sein Kandidat ist Kemal Kilic danulu
Chef der größten Oppositionspartei CHP
ein freundlicher Mann ehemaliger
Staatsbeamter einer der versöhnen will
der das Präsidialsystem abschaffen die
Demokratie stärken will nicht alle sind
glücklich mit seiner Kandidatur auch
viele der jungen Wähler nicht die aber
endlich einen neuen Präsidenten wollen
ich war nicht für Rollo als Kandidat
aber weil er jetzt nun mal der Kandidat
ist unterstützt mir natürlich
er ist für mich kein guter Politiker ich
wollte jetzt nicht aber im Moment habe
ich keine andere Wahl
ich mir eine es geht um Erdogan ja oder
nein das sieht auch Nagern alte so
politikanalysten des Senders habertürk
es sei ein Showdown um die Macht in
einem gespaltenen Land der Wahlausgang
sei völlig offen sagt sie es wäre sehr
eng und das könne Probleme geben
falls
50,2% oder 50,1% gewinnen wird wird
Erdogan und seine Supporter sagen seine
unterstütze sagen okay sowas es waren
schöne 22 Jahre das ist jetzt vorbei das
glaube ich nicht die Gesellschaft ist so
wie schwarz und weiß das ist sehr schwer
ist das Ergebnis zu akzeptieren die
Regierung macht Wahlkampf indem sie
Ängste führt die Wahl sei ein putscht
versucht das Ausland sagte Innenminister
Erdogan selbst behauptet sein Gegner
paktiere mit Terroristen werde das Land
in den Abgrund treiben
die Oppositionen in diesem Land lügt
verleumdet manipuliert und versucht mit
geheimen Deals an die Regierung zu
kommen
solche Sprüche zeigen bei einstigen
stammwäldern des Präsidenten Wirkung wie
hier in Istanbul Mustafa Jenner Holo
versucht ihnen die Angst zu nehmen zum
Beispiel davor dass ein Wahlsieger
kilica UNO Religion und konservative
Werte zurückdrängen könnte die Ängste
die sind natürlich da und die muss man
verstehen und damit muss man sich
auseinandersetzen auch die JP muss ich
damit auseinandersetzen
sagt wenn alles mit rechten Dingen
zugeht werden wir gewinnen doch alles
könne passieren man lebe schließlich in
der Türkei
alles können passieren unser chorusement
Jörg brasis und das Istanbul
zugeschaltet Jörg du hast natürlich auch
keine Kristallkugel aber so dieses
korrespondentengefühl das Beobachter
Gefühl ist deine Wechselstimmung in der
Luft
also ich denke schon dass da eine
Wechselstimmung in der Luft liegt aber
das hängt natürlich immer auch davon ab
mit wem man da redet wir haben es ja
eben im Beitrag gesehen es gibt auch
viele die Angst haben vor einer
Regierung kilica Ole und diese Angst die
wird eben geschürt auch durch die Medien
macht der Regierung in den meisten
Fernsehsendern tauchte die Oppositionen
ihr Wahlkampf kaum auf dafür aber umso
mehr der Wahlkampf von Präsident Erdogan
trotzdem sehen die meisten Umfrage
Institute die Opposition das Bündnis und
dann kann die Daten vorne einige mit
knapp über 50%, das würde dann einen
Sieg im ersten Wahlgang bedeuten aber
viele eben auch knapp darunter und das
würde dann heißen dass es zwei Wochen
später zu einer Stichwahl zu einem
zweiten Wahlgang kommen könnte dann
haben wir eben von der türkischen
Kollegin gehört dass sie sagte also dass
Erdogan und seine ganze Clique und seine
familienplan dass sie nach zwei über 20
Jahren sagen okay wir haben verloren
wenn es so käme kein Problem wir ziehen
aus das kann man sich schwer vorstellen
und wir haben den USA erlebt
schon nach fünf Jahren ist da jemanden
sehr schwer viel auszuziehen was für
Befürchtungen gibt es da
es gibt natürlich viele Befürchtungen
und
Ängste so ist zum Beispiel heute hat
Kemal Kilic daolo und auch andere
Wahlkämpfer der Opposition die sind auf
ihren
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen mit
schusswesten unter ihren Hemden
aufgetreten da hieß es dass es Hinweise
gegeben habe auf geplante Anschläge ob
das stimmt das weiß man natürlich nicht
aber auf der anderen Seite hat Präsident
Erdogan heute getwittert dass er und
seine Unterstützer bereit wären in der
Nacht zum Montag die Freiheit und
Unabhängigkeit der Türkei wenn nötig mit
ihrem Leben zu verteidigen das spielt an
auf den Putschversuch 2016 das ist
natürlich ein Spiel mit dem Feuer und
man will sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
es da tatsächlich zur Ausschreitung
kommt wahrscheinlich ist es eher dass
der Unterlegene versuchen wird das
Wahlergebnis anzufechten vor der
Wahlbehörde vor den Gerichten die sind
ja wie man weiß allerdings größtenteils
unter Kontrolle der Regierung die
meisten hoffen also das ist ein klares
Ergebnis es gibt das dann die
unterlegene Seite anerkennen muss
anerkennen kann aber die Umfragen geben
das im Moment leider nicht her
Dankeschön Jörg nach Istanbul und mir
zur Wahl in der Türkei haben wir online
auf ZDF heute für sie unter anderem ein
Interview mit der Journalistin
michalettolo und am Sonntag am Alltag
sendet das heute journal live aus Ankara
der künftig in Deutschland gewählt wird
damit geht es bei dir jetzt weiter
Hannah ja die Wahlrechtsreform durch die
der Bundestag pardon verkleinert werden
soll kann in Kraft treten nachdem das
Vorhaben heute auch den Bundesrat
passiert hat mit der Neuregelung werden
die sogenannten Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate abgeschafft dadurch
soll die Abgeordneten Zahl auf 630
begrenzt werden aktuell liegt sie bei
736 die Reform ist umstritten weil
dadurch Kandidaten die ihren Wahlkreis
direkt gewonnen haben nicht mehr
automatisch in den Bundestag einziehen
der bayerische Ministerpräsident Söder
kündigte eine Klage des Freistaats vor
dem Bundesverfassungsgericht an
die außenministerinnen und Minister der
EU haben sich heute in Stockholm
getroffen um über den zukünftigen Umgang
mit China zu beraten und eng damit
verbunden auch über das geplante 11
Sanktionspaket gegen Moskau bisherige
Sanktionen verbieten den Export vieler
Produkte von Europa nach Russland mit
Drittstaaten werden diese allerdings
umgangen offenbar auch aus China das
neue Sanktionspaket der EU-Kommission
sieht nun vor diese Umgehungen ganz
konkret zu bekämpfen etwa durch
exportverbote oder Strafmaßnahmen gegen
einzelne Firmen
zu Lage in der Ukraine dort gibt es
offenbar Bewegung rund um die schwer
umkämpfte statt bachmut im Osten des
Landes Präsident selenski meldet in der
Region Geländegewinne Russland sei zum
Teil zurückgedrängt worden sollen auch
diese Bilder des ukrainischen Militärs
belegen zugleich äußerte der Chef der
russischen Söldnertruppe Wagner scharfe
Kritik am russischen Militär Soldaten
hätten in bachmut die Flucht ergriffen
erklärte in einem Video
einen Tag nach der schweren Explosion in
einem Ratinger Hochhaus haben die
Ermittler heute weitere Details bekannt
gegeben so geht mal mittlerweile von
einer vorsätzlichen Tat aus der
57-Jährige Verdächtige habe die
Einsatzkräfte gezielt mit einer
brennbaren Flüssigkeit attackiert zudem
wurden mehrere Waffen bei dem Mann
gefunden bei der Explosion gestern
wurden 33 Einsatzkräfte von Polizei und
Feuerwehr verletzt fünf von ihnen
lebensgefährlich gegen den
Tatverdächtigen wurde Haftbefehl wegen
versuchten Mordes in neuen Fällen
erlassen
zum heutigen internationalen Tag der
Pflege haben in Berlin hunderte Menschen
für bessere Rahmenbedingungen in diesem
Bereich demonstriert kritisiert wurden
unter anderem eine schlechte Bezahlung
zu wenig Unterstützung für pflegende
Angehörige sowie stetig steigende
Beiträge für die Pflegeversicherung
deshalb sei eine grundlegende Struktur
und Finanzreform nötig
[Applaus]
was die Demonstranten anprangern also
schlechte Bezahlung schlechte
Arbeitsbedingungen Personalmangel das
ist alles ja seit langem bekannt in der
Pandemie wurde es dann noch mal
besonders sichtbar wie unter einem
Brennglas aber es gibt in der Pflege
noch einen zweiten Arbeitsmarkt in dem
der Beruf wesentlich attraktiver ist es
wird gut bezahlt man kann sich
zwischendurch sogar längere Auszeiten
nehmen und schon wieder für den
Nachtdienst einspringen weil eine
Kollegin erkrankt ist das muss man auch
nicht dass sich dieser zweite
Arbeitsmarkt gebildet hat hängt
natürlich mit den Bedingungen des ersten
zusammen mehr dazu von Stefanie gargosch
und Lukas Peuser
5 Uhr am Morgen Frühstück vor der Arbeit
Franziska Kley ist Pflegerin auf der
Intensivstation als zeitarbeiterin das
heißt eine Firma vermittelt sie ein
Kliniken denen Personal fehlt nach
Jahren in einer Festanstellung hat sie
sich bewusst dafür entschieden weil sie
etwa 700 Euro mehr verdient und die
Arbeitsbedingungen ihr besser gefallen
ich gebe mein Dienstplan meinen
wunschdienstplan ab und ich werde oder
ich bekomme Rückmeldung möchtest du dann
und dann dort arbeiten und ich kann ja
oder nein sagen also ich bin absolut
flexibel ich kann Urlaub machen war
nicht möchte wie lange ich möchte und
das war bei meiner Festanstellung in der
Klinik leider nicht immer möglich das
Problem dabei die Zeitarbeit in den
Kliniken nimmt in den großen Städten
massiv zu Spitzenreiter Berlin über 9%
des Pflegepersonals kam mir 2022 aus der
Zeitarbeit was die Ausnahme sein soll
wird zum Arbeitsmodell dabei leidet die
Qualität der Pflege durch die Zeitarbeit
weil das Personal ständig wechselt und
sie ist teuer die Kliniken schlagen
Alarm
Krankenhäuser haben enorme Kosten die
Zeitarbeit verbunden sind
eine Pflegekraft wird von den Kassen im
pflegebudget vollständig vergütet nicht
aber die Zeitarbeit die enormen Kosten
von bis zu 150 Euro die Stunde die
werden nicht rückfinanziert das heißt
die Krankenhäuser bleiben auf diesen
hohen Kosten pro Stunde extra sitzen zum
Vergleich eine Festangestellte
Pflegekraft verdient im Schnitt 25 € in
Berlin haben die Krankenhäuser nun einen
Mustervertrag ausgearbeitet der will die
Zeitarbeitsfirmen verpflichten die Löhne
zu deckeln und die Qualität zu
verbessern bindend ist der Vertrag nicht
und für die Gewerkschaften der falsche
Weg man müsste endlich auf die
Bedürfnisse der Pflegekräfte eingehen
Pflegekräfte sagen wir brauchen bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen wir brauchen vor
allem mehr Personal wir brauchen stabile
Dienstpläne wir wollen nicht ständig in
unserer Freizeit angerufen werden ob wir
arbeiten kommen und wir wollen
gewertschätzt werden wir wollen dass
diese wichtige und professionelle Arbeit
die wir machen auch angemessen vergütet
wird und angemessen gesehen wird Marlen
Meinecke ist Pflegeexpertin und
festangestellt nach Jahren der
Zeitarbeit am Ende so sagt sie er trug
sie den ständigen Wechsel nicht mehr die
Nachteile der Zeitarbeit für sie
insgesamt zu hoch ich werde als Team
Mitglied nicht wahrgenommen und die
andere Konsequenz ist dass ich
bei den Patientinnen keine
nachhaltige Qualität bringen kann und
das belastet mich natürlich und ich
glaube wenn man das für sich merkt und
ein die patientenqualität wichtig ist
dann geht man zurück ins Krankenhaus in
Festanstellung fest steht die Auswüchse
der Zeitarbeit resultieren aus der
Schieflage der Arbeitsbedingungen bis
diese sich ändern Zahlen Pfleger der
Patient und die Kliniken drauf und die
Zeitarbeitsfirmen profitieren
im Bundestag wurde heute der
Staatsgründung Israels vor 75 Jahren
gedacht ein erinnern in angespannten
Zeiten diese Woche flogen aus dem
Gazastreifen wieder hunderte Raketen auf
Israel der Konflikt mit den
Palästinensern bleibt ungelöst zugleich
ist das Land innenpolitisch in der
vielleicht schwersten Krise seit
Staatsgründung Regierungschef nitaniao
wird vorgeworfen an den Grundfesten von
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
rütteln jene Werte die Israel so
deutlich von seiner östlichen Nachbarn
unterscheidet sorgen die bei aller
Solidaritätsbekundung auch im Bundestag
angesprochen wurden Frank Buchwald und
Britta Spiekermann Berichten aus Berlin
mehreren Mendel ist in beiden Ländern zu
Hause der Mann aus Israel leitet die
deutsche Bildungsstätte Anne Frank seit
Jahren forschte über die Sicht der
deutschen auf Israel die Debatte im
Bundestag zum 75 jahrestag der Gründung
Israels verfolgte mit Interesse
das Israel uns die Hand gereicht hat das
ist etwas für das wir immer dankbar sein
werden und es ist unsere Verantwortung
für immer die Sicherheit Israels ist
deutsche staats-saison wirklich in
Sicherheit aber hat Israel bisher nie
gelebt Raketenangriffe gehören zum
Alltag ebenso Attacken militante
Palästinenser und nicht nur das das
Regime der Müllers und
Revolutionswächter verfolgt nach wie vor
seit 1979 das Ziel Israel von der
Weltkarte zu tilgen dieses Regime ist
heute der Verursacher beinahe aller
Konflikten im Namen um Mittleren Osten
auch im Innern steht Israel unter Druck
eine umstritten Justizreform von
Ministerpräsident Netanjahu treibt
hunderttausende Menschen auf die Straße
seit Monaten schon viele sehen die
Demokratie in Gefahr vorsichtige Kritik
auch im Bundestag gewandelt in
Anerkennung mein Eindruck ist dieses
Ringen in Israel um die eigene Identität
und die staatlichen Institutionen das
ist keine Schwäche des Systems sondern
ist Ausdruck der Stärke der israelischen
Demokratie auf der Ehrentribüne der
Bundespräsident mit Israels
Botschafterin prosor fast alle Redner
warnen vor zunehmendem Antisemitismus so
viel Hass so viel Wut so viel
Beleidigung auch gegenüber Israel
gegenüber Jüdinnen und Juden habe ich in
meinen 25 Jahren Parlaments
Zugehörigkeit noch nie erlebt wenig
Kontroversen in der Debatte beim Thema
Israel herrscht große Einigkeit Kritik
Belehrungen gab immer heikel im Hohen
Haus dabei könnten auch die Deutschen
sich durchaus mutiger positionieren
meint mehr und Mendel der Pädagoge aus
Israel es wäre gut wenn die wenn die
deutsche Politik nicht nur auf unsere
Selbstbild rekoriert dass wir aus der
aus der Vergangenheit gelernt haben und
deswegen finden wir Israel so toll
sondern das weil wir aus der Geschichte
gelernt haben sind wir auch in der Lage
die aktuellen und der alle politische
Zustände in Israel zu kritisieren und
das ist ein Zeichen eine wahre Zeichen
der Freundschaft ganz unbefangen kann
das Verhältnis der Deutschen zu Israel
eben immer noch nicht sein auch 75 Jahre
nach Gründung des jüdischen Staates die
Schatten der Shoa sind lang für Menschen
wie mehrere Mendel bleibt deshalb noch
viel zu tun
Schleswig-Holstein hofft auf einen
wichtigen
unternehmenszuzug damit geht es jetzt
bei Hannah noch mal weiter ja nördlich
von Hamburg in Heide könnte schon bald
eine milliardenschwere
batteriezellenfabrik des schwedischen
Herstellers North world gebaut werden
das Unternehmen hat heute angekündigt
das Vorhaben vorantreiben zu wollen und
überzeugt haben dabei wohl auch
umfangreiche Staatshilfen die in
Aussicht gestellt wurden Valerie Haller
was würde der Bau dieser Fabrik für die
Region aber auch für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland bedeuten
nun das wäre insofern erfreulich da
europäische Autobauer bislang fast
vollständig von Batterien aus Asien
abhängig sind der Bedarf ja riesig ist
und auch immer größer wird die neue
Fabrik könnte ein Standortvorteil also
sein für Europas Autohersteller sie
könnte ab 2026 Millionen Autos mit
Batterien versorgen ja und darüber
hinaus hofft Schleswig-Holstein auch auf
neue Jobs 3000 in der Fabrik und
womöglich einige Taus mehr in Industrie
und Dienstleistungen lange war aber
ungewiss ob sich die Schweden für
Deutschland entscheiden warum genau weil
sich ein batterie-fabrikant aussuchen
kann wo er seine Anlage hinstellt um
Zukunftstechnologien reißen sich viele
zurzeit die USA die Locken ja mit hohen
Fördergeldern Deutschland war da
zunächst zurückhaltende und erst nach
dem Angebot aus Berlin die Anlage zu
fördern kam dann auch die Zusage aus
Schweden da könnte sich im Laufe der
Zeit ein regelrechter
Subventionswettlauf anbahnen zwischen
den USA und der EU Nord erwägt nun den
Bau eines weiteren Werks und zwar in
Nordamerika ganz nach dem Motto wenn
sich zwei streiten dann freut sich der
Dritte in dem Fall das schwedische neues
Wort
vielen Dank Valerie für designordnung
nachdem twitter-chef Elon Musk seinen
Rückzug von der Spitze der Plattform
bekannt gegeben hat verkündet er heute
wer ihm nachfolgen wird seine Wahl ist
auf die werbeexpertin Linda yakarino
gefallen diese leitete zuletzt das
globale Anzeigengeschäft bei
Medienunternehmen NBC Universe soll nun
helfen wieder Werbekunden auf die
Plattform zu locken viele hatten Twitter
nach der Übernahme von Maske im
vergangenen Oktober den Rücken gekehrt
der versucht den 50-stündigen Bahnstreik
ab Sonntagabend doch noch abzuwenden ist
gescheitert das hat die Gewerkschaft EVG
bekannt gegeben auch die jüngsten
Verhandlungen mit der Deutschen Bahn
brachten keinen Durchbruch ein Ultimatum
am Mittag sei ohne neues Angebot
verstrichen von Sonntagabend 22 Uhr bis
Dienstag um Mitternacht wird der
Fernverkehr der Deutschen Bahn komplett
eingestellt auch im Regionalverkehr wird
kaum ein Zug fahren zum Sport die
Eishockey-WM in Finnland und Lettland
hat begonnen gleich zum Auftakt musste
das deutsche Team gegen den elf maligen
Weltmeister und Turnier mit Favorit
Schweden ran dass die eb-team schlug
sich lange Zeit beachtlich verlor am
Ende dann aber doch knapp mit eins zu
null
in Berlin läuft zur Stunde der Deutsche
Filmpreis schon gewonnen hat der Oskar
prämierte Anti-Kriegsfilm im Westen
nichts Neues mit bislang acht Preisen
bei 12 Nominierungen ist der Netflix
Film der große Gewinner des Abends vier
Lolas gingen an die zdf-produktion das
Lehrerzimmer unter anderem für das beste
Drehbuch die gesamte Verleihung können
Sie sich in unserer Mediathek oder um
23:30 Uhr hier im ZDF ansehen
und dann von uns noch einen aktueller
Filmtipp jetzt neu im Kino angelaufen
adios Buenos Aires das Spielfilm Debüt
des deutsch-argentinischen Regisseurs
Hermann Karl er zog einst nach
Deutschland um an der Filmhochschule in
München zu studieren und mit Wimpern das
zu arbeiten beides gelangen bisher
drehte Hermann Krahl Dokumentarfilme
sehr erfolgreich war zum Beispiel sein
tänzerportrait ein letzter Tango
produziert von den Benders die Musik des
Tango und Buenos Aires stehen nun auch
im Mittelpunkt seines Spielfilms eine
Geschichte die auch seine eigene erzählt
dass man von seiner Heimat nicht
loskommt auch wenn man gute Gründe hatte
sie zu verlassen
Nadja nasser hat sich den Film angesehen
[Musik]
Argentinien im Krisen Winter 2001 unsere
Gage für heute Abend drei na dass wir
jeden großartig entweder wir retten uns
gemeinsam oder wir gehen gemeinsam
runter
was für ein Land was für ein Land Tango
Musik
in seinem so geliebten aber auch
kaputten Land er denkt wie so viele ans
Auswandern
von wollen ist keine Rede
was soll ich sagen im Grunde bricht mir
das Herz in Italien
Australien
ihr Auto machen die Leute als erstes zu
Geld
das Land verlassen wollen das ist
natürlich eine Krise die in Argentinien
sehr sehr stark war und die Argentinien
sehr geprägt hat zu sehen dass die
Themen die damals
präsent waren
heute 20 Jahre später genauso präsent
sind also Auslandsschulen und IWF
Armut Korruption
Auswanderung soziale Unzufriedenheit
schlimmste wirklich in so einem Land
leben dann rauscht ihm auch noch die
temperamentvolle Taxifahrerin Daniela
ins Auto und ins Leben
seine Pläne erstmal futscht
mich nicht gleich beleidigen
die Leute mir das Geld dass sie nicht
haben in den Mund den ich nicht habe
Geld Abhebungen von 250 PSUs pro Woche
als die Regierung den Geldhahn zu dreht
scheint alles aus
was bleibt sind die Menschen um ihn
herum und mit ihnen immer ein bisschen
Hoffnung
[Musik]
denn sonst gibt es natürlich die die
Liebe zum Musik die diese Musiker haben
die Liebenden Tango überall
das ist das was ihnen Kraft gibt und um
weiterzuleben die Geschichte von diesem
Menschen aus Argentinien die das Erleben
und trotzdem nicht aufgeben es ist
definitiv eine Liebeserklärung an den
Tango und an Buenos Aires
und adios Buenos Aires ist ein Film der
selbst ein bisschen ist wie ein Tango
seine Figuren im hin und her der Gefühle
mal melancholisch mal euphorisch mit
viel Witz und Liebe erzählt
[Musik]
es war von uns gleich geht's mit der
heute schon weiter und morgen Abend
begrüßen Sie sich hier und eine galine
auf Wiedersehen wir wünschen noch einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf unserer
Wetterkarte herrschen umgekehrte
Verhältnisse nach Norden in hoher
Luftdruck und im Süden tiefer Luftdruck
diese Konstellation ist recht stabil und
dementsprechend regnet es über den Alpen
auch weiter in den Bergen gibt es Schnee
Richtung Balkan ebenfalls Regen und auch
in Frankreich kommen Schauer auf ja und
in der Nacht gibt es im südenschauer und
nach Westen auch sonst ist es aber
trocken ganz im Norden Stern klar am
Alpenrand singen die Temperaturen auf
vier Grad und 11 Grad im Rheinland das
ist die Temperaturspanne Morgen viel
Sonnenschein im Norden im Osten einige
harmlose Wolken sonst aber auch Schauer
und Gewitter in der Mitte die im
Tagesverlauf aufkommen und westwärts
ziehen auch im Süden ist es teilweise
dicht bewölkt mit Blitz und Donner
Temperaturen dort bis 14 Grad aber
schauen Sie nach Norden in 22 bis 24
Grad hier Richtung Berlin zum Beispiel
recht warm ähnlich warm auch 18 bis 21
Grad ganz im Norden ja das ist schon ein
recht warmer Tag morgen und die nächsten
Tage Schauer und Gewitter setzen sich
fort am Sonntag im Norden teilweise
sonnig bei 14 bis 23 Grad ja und die
Schauer erreichen dann ab Montag
allmählich auch den Norden und damit
wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend